out
hors de la boîte lorsque j'ai découvert
le sujet de ce thé dictée août
je ne suis dit tout de suite ouais ça ça
me parle
la boîte cette fameuse boîte que je
connais tellement bien parce que moi
gaza les i
j'ai passé ma vie en fait à moto placée
dans des boîtes
peut-être que vous connaissez la même
expérience vous savez ce que c'est
d'être dans une boîte mais pour moi la
première expérience que j'ai eu avec la
boîte c'était lorsque j'étais au cp à
cette époque
j'habitais en métropole mon père qui
avait une carrière militaire était
souvent muté dans différentes villes et
en fait ce qui s'était passé c'est que
moi j'ai fait 4 cp non pas que j'ai
redoublé quatre fois le cpe non mais
j'ai fait 4 cp en une année parce que
mon père était déplacée à chaque fois
dans différentes villes et donc une fois
je suis arrivé dans une nouvelle école
et à la récréation ce qui se passait
bien comme un enfant j'ai envie de
découvrir les autres envie de me faire
de nouveaux amis et surtout envie de
m'amuser
donc je vais voir les enfants je leur
demande fait qu'est ce que vous faites
ils me disent on est en train de jouer
au los che c'est quoi le loup c'est la
même chose que le maire ici à la réunion
et il me dit viens viens jacques nous
explique les règles et moi ce que je
retiens c'est court vite et tu te fais
pas attraper ses basiques c'est très
simple pour moi je me dis ok c'est bon
allons-y j'y vais durant toute la
récréation j'ai couru quand même malade
j'ai couru couru couru couru et je me
suis pas fait attraper une seule fois
yes j'étais le gagnant est le lendemain
la même chose je vais voir mes amis je
leur dis ok aujourd'hui on joue à quoi
au loup super allons-y est à nouveau je
cours je cours je cours je cours et je
ne me fais pas attraper de nouveau et je
passe ainsi tout mais récréation pendant
tous les jours qui viennent à un courir
à jouer louer ne jamais me faire
attraper
jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce qu'un jour
pardon j'arrive devant mes amis je leur
dis ok aujourd'hui on joue au loup il
fonda en un an à temps nous on joue au
loup mais toi tu joues pas avec nous je
les regarde je refais mais pourquoi
titouan gaël c'est simple tu cours trop
vite on peut pas attraper c'est pas
amusant de jouer avec toi vas t'en on
veut pas de toi à ce moment là cette
parole qu'ils m'ont dit c'était
l'équivalent comme si il avait pris un
couteau
il me l'avait planté là dans le coeur
parce qu'à ce moment là ce que j'ai
ressenti
pour la première fois c'était le rejet
se faire exclure du groupe et se
retrouver seul
cette sensation était tellement
douloureuse que les jours qui ont suivi
j'ai même pas osé aller revoir les
enfants alors demandé si je pouvais
jouer avec non ce que j'avais fait
c'était que j'avais préparé mes petites
figurines de tortues ninja et j'avais
emmené avec moi à l'école et je jouais
tout seul dans mon coin et je regardais
les autres les enfants qui couraient qui
s'amusaient mais moi j'étais tout seul
dans mon coin à jouer et à ce moment là
je me suis fait en fait une promesse à
ce moment là je me suis dit à moi-même
je ne fais plus jamais de ma vie je ne
vais vivre cela plus jamais je vais me
faire exclure parce que ça fait beaucoup
trop mal et donc je vais mettre en place
certaines règles qui vont permettre
justement de toujours rester dans le
groupe
la première de ces règles c'était adapte
toi et fais comme tout le monde
en ayant mis cette règle en place ce que
j'ai fait eh bien j'avais ouvert la
boîte et j'étais rentré dans cette boîte
j'avais décidé de moi-même mettre dans
une boîte et d'être conformes à ce qu'au
fond tous les gens comme je vous l'aï
dit mon père qui avait une carrière
militaire
j'ai eu la chance que cette situation
n'a pas duré pour moi parce que quelques
semaines après on était déjà dans une
nouvelle ville et c'était pour moi une
nouvelle école et donc forcément
nouvelle école 10 nouveaux amis et comme
j'avais retenu la leçon
je courais pas comme un malade quand on
jouait au loup et je me faisais attrapé
de temps en temps ce qui faisait que les
enfants m'avait acceptée dans leur
groupe ce qu'il s'est passé c'est que
l'année suivante
mon père a pris sa retraite militaire et
il est venu à la réunion pour reprendre
la station-service de sa mère donc toute
la famille on était arrivés sur l'île de
la réunion l'île natale de mes parents
arrivés sur cette île ce qu'il s'est
passé c'est que comme tous les autres
fois j'arrivais dans une nouvelle école
et donc à ce moment là je me retrouvais
à nouveau avec de nouveaux enfants avec
qui jouer et l'appareil je demande un
pont jouer nos fonds ont joué au maire
le loup est donc là je dis ok je connais
la règle c'est facile il me suffit juste
de courir tranquillement et de me faire
attraper temps en temps
premier jour c'est ce que je fais les
enfants m'attrape mais je vois que avec
les réunionnais ya quelque chose d'un
peu différent c'est à dire que il court
quand même assez vite ces réunionnais
voix et donc à ce moment-là je me dis me
va peut-être falloir que moi aussi je
commence à courir un jour alors je me
décide de dire ok allez on va faire le
test
on court comme un malade comme je le
faisais avant et là c'est ce que je fais
et je me fais quand même attrapé je me
dis mais attend en fait à la réunion on
a le droit de couvrir comme un malade
en fait on a le droit d'être soi et de
continuer à courir comme on a envie il
n'y a pas cette boîte à la réunion en
fait
et là je peux vous dire la libération
que j'ai senti en moi comme si en fait
cette boîte dans lesquels je m'étais
mise elle a disparu je pouvais enfin
jouer de la manière que j'avais envie
est de faire exactement comme je le
sentais mais comme je vous ai dit ma vie
c'est une relation avec cette boîte est
donc forcément même si je m'étais
libérer de cette boîte
j'ai eu à nouveau une expérience
similaire
cette nouvelle expérience avec la boîte
c'était lorsque j'étais au collège
lorsque j'étais au collège et mon père
qui est venu me voir un jour et il m'a
dit gaëlle samedi tu vas venir avec moi
je vais te présenter quelqu'un qui a des
yeux là là là et là je fais la même tête
que vous en
il m'a dit ça j'ai fait quoi des quoi tu
me parles que
mais à ce moment-là je me dis ok moi qui
suis curieux allons-y et en fait il m'a
emmené voir son oncle à sainte-rose qui
est un guérisseur réunionnais la
particularité d'un guérisseur
réunionnais c'est une personne qui par
la prière à la capacité de guérir des
gens il m'avait emmené en fait dans sa
chapelle plus particulièrement et ce qui
m'avait marqué moi dans la chapelle de
son oncle c'était que toutes les
religions y étaient représentées dans un
même lieu
nous avions du bouddhisme du
catholicisme de l'hindouisme de l'islam
toutes les religions y était en un même
lieu
il faut savoir que pour ma part mon père
ne m'avait pas baptisé il avait pris la
décision de se dire je ne baptise pas
mon enfant parce que lorsqu'il sera en
âge de choisir il le fera lui même ce
n'est pas à moi de lui imposer une
religion et à ce moment là moi qui était
quand même en quête de pouvoir exprimer
ce lien que je sentais en moi depuis
tout petit un lien avec quelque chose de
plus grand que moi
appelez le dieu appelé le la mère nature
ap le l'univers comme vous le souhaitez
mais pour moi c'était vraiment un besoin
viscéral d'exprimer ce lien et forcément
lorsque j'ai découvert ce lieu cette
chapelle
j'avais enfin la réponse
1 comment exprimer ce lien je trouvais
l'endroit où justement je pouvais
exprimer cette ce lien avec dieu
cette notion de spiritualité qui était
tellement cher pour moi et donc du coup
empressé partout l'enthousiaste que
j'avais eu le lundi j'ai un revenu au
collège allé voir mon pote et je faisais
tu sais qu est ce qui s'est passé samedi
pour moi je suis parti dans une chapelle
il y avait toutes les religions il ya un
monsieur et guérissent et les gens avec
de la prière et là mon pote il m'a
regardé et m'a fait tu es parti ou et ça
c'est des histoires de marabout de
deviner a de fait le sort des choses
comme ça ça nous et moi je veux pas
connaître tout ça et on est là à ce
nouveau tout de suite ce qui s'est passé
en moi c'était flash back à la période
du cp à ce moment là je me suis pour à
nouveau pensé que si je continue à
parler de cela on allait à nouveau
m'exclure on allait à nouveau me rejeter
du coup ce que je me suis tout de suite
dit j'avais quand même compris la leçon
je savais ce qui pouvait se passer je me
suis dit non à temps changent de sujet
là ça de côté et surtout n'en parle plus
c'est un sujet tabou et à ce moment là
lorsque je me suis dit justement cette
nouvelle règle n'en parle plus à nouveau
j'ouvrais la porte de la boîte et je
rentrais dans cette boîte à nouveau
j'avais cette règle que ce qui était
aussi cher pour moi et qui me faisait
tellement de plaisir je ne devais pas le
partager je devais le garder uniquement
pour moi et donc j'ai continué en fait
au fil des années à expérimenter
justement cette relation dans cette
chapelle avec dieu à pouvoir justement
une fois par mois il ya les laisse
exprimer ce qu'il y avait dans mon coeur
et les autres jouent en faire comme si
je vivais une vie normale j'avais un peu
comme une double vie mais cela était
pour moi équilibré ça ne posait pas
vraiment de problème d'ailleurs mon père
lui avait continué vraiment à s'investir
avec son oncle il avait été initié par
son oncle et il a d'ailleurs pris lui
aussi la décision d'avoir sa propre
chapelle et devenir lui-même guérisseur
réunionnais et donc forcément moi qui
l'accompagné j'ai aussi été initiés à
montpon avec à ce que mon père faisait
du coup ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
2017 lorsque mon père lui a pris son
envol pour un autre monde
j'étais face à un dilemme je devais
faire un choix est-ce que j'allais
continuer tout ce que m'avait légué mon
père ou est ce que j'écoutais en fait
cette peur que j'avais de me dire non
surtout ne fait pas ça tu n'as pas le
droit de parler de ce sujet si tu toi tu
investis autant comment tu vas faire sur
le court je m'étais dit bon je vais
continuer à faire comme j'ai l'habitude
de faire c'est à dire que je vais
continuer à vivre ma spiritualité mais
de manière cachée de manière à ne pas le
montrer à tout le monde
mais ce qu'il y avait changé c'est que
j'étais quand même mois l'officiant
aujourd'hui dans cette chatel ce qui a
fait que chaque jour en fait j'avais un
conflit intérieur qui devenait de plus
en plus puissants j'avais une voix qui
me disait galles
tu vois comment tu aimes ça tu vois
comment tu aimes cette expression de la
spiritualité
cette liaison avec dieu ça te fait
tellement du bien tu devrais l'exprimer
tu devrais vraiment le montrer à tout le
monde et j'avais une autre voie qui me
dit mais tu es complètement fou ne fait
surtout pas ça si tu fais ça tu vas
retrouver à nouveau seul ça n'a pas
servi de leçon c'est fait et voilà tous
les jours ce que j'entendais et comme
j'étais dans une boîte
ça faisait écho j'avais un brouhaha
constant dans ma tête qui me disait fait
le ne le fait pas fait le ne le fait pas
fait le ne le fait pas et ça devenait de
plus en plus un supplice cette boîte qui
au départ me protéger de d'être exclu
devenez en fait un lieu oppressant parce
que je sentais de plus en plus son poids
sur moi comme si elle se refermer chaque
jour sur moi et cette douleur devenait
de plus en plus dur j'avais cette envie
d'exprimer et pourtant je la condenser
je me sentais enfermé cloître est de
plus en plus jusqu'à ce que et bien
j'entende parler justement du tedx you
out of the box out of the box hors de la
boîte mais oui la voilà ma réponse si
cette boîte me fait aussi mal pourquoi
ne pas sortir de cette boîte alors eh
bien justement sortir de la boîte
c'est ce que j'ai décidé de faire
aujourd'hui en fait c'est de profiter
justement d'être devant vous tous et de
pouvoir partager mon message pour vous
dire que je le fais je décide
aujourd'hui de sortir de la boîte je
décide aujourd'hui de révéler à tout le
monde que je suis descendant d'une
lignée de personnes qui sont guérisseur
de personnes qui ont cette capacité de
guérir par la prière et qui ont une
chapelle à où toutes les religions sont
présentes
merci mais ce soir je souhaitais surtout
partager ce message avec vous parce
qu'il ya une notion importante parce que
je sais que je vous ai parlé de la boîte
justement et je sais que parmi vous il y
à des personnes qui sont aussi dans
cette boîte
il ya aussi des personnes qui parmi vous
se sentent oppressés par cette boîte
vous avez tous chacun d'entre vous une
voix à l'intérieur de vous qui vous dit
suis ton coeur fait le csah tué sept
personnes la exprime le sort de la boîte
beaucoup d'entre vous ressentent la
pression de cette boîte est bien ce que
je veux partager avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce que j'ai fait
j'ai ouvert la porte de la boîte
nous sommes maintenant tous capables de
pouvoir sortir de cette boîte parce que
la porte est grande ouverte
alors ceux qui veulent me suivre je vous
invite tous à prendre le chemin et
sortir de la boîte
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]